you know like you you start to like lose
you start to lose your ability
um or like your flexibility for like
life like your ability to cope with just
everyday emotions and everyday problems
that people see
you know as um as totally common and
regular and
I think as a drug addict also you you
start to become like ashamed of your
inability to do those things or your
inability to function properly
or even just you know anxieties that
that come out of nowhere and and that
perpetuates
you know self-sabotage and destructive
Tendencies too because it's like how do
you have like that self-esteem of doing
these things when you know you you
aren't even sure how to do these things
or you aren't noticing things that that
need to be addressed or you know it
it's so like I said I mean just to like
repeat any problem that I have right now
um
it's directly linked to my drug
addiction living down here is directly
with